[Musique]
en face la situation est difficile donc
et il est évident qu'il fallait réagir
les personnes qui se trouvent
actuellement en réanimation
on a trois quarts qui ne sont pas
vaccinés ça parle quand même
de façon évidente pour en faveur de la
nécessité de cette vaccination certains
hôpitaux sont saturés à l'hôpital de
fribourg en brisgau par exemple et les
services de réanimation
sont en flux tendu
[Musique]
il y aura des bas mais à mon avis je
n'ai pas énormément de doutes sur le
fait que cette obligation vaccinale va
finir par arriver mais on ne veut en
aucun cas dire que le forcerait
quelqu'un par là on l'utilisera la force
pour les vacciner c'est pas la même
chose alors je pense que des sanctions
sont envisageables bien sûr mais en
aucun cas on ne vaccine ray les gens par
la force
[Musique]